vier menschen sind tot dutzende verletzt
die rettungsarbeiten laufen immer noch
schreckliches zugunglück im garmisch
partenkirchen am letzten schultag vor
den ferien entgleist gegen 12.15 ein
regionalzug zwischen garmisch und
oberammergau
es liegen auf der seite es sei nicht
ausgeschlossen dass unter den opfern
auch viele schüler sind feuerwehr und
polizei sind mit einem großaufgebot vor
ort auch drei rettungshubschrauber aus
tirol sind im einsatz sowie
einsatzkräfte der bundeswehr die
bahnstrecke zwischen
garmisch-partenkirchen und ober
ausgesperrt die deutsche bahn plant
einen ersatzverkehr nach angaben des
zuständigen landesamtes werden derzeit
rund 60 menschen mit verletzungen
behandelt 16 davon mit schweren wie es
zum unfall kam ist noch unklar die
ermittlungen laufen
vor ort ist unser reporter kalk ein
karl was weiß man inzwischen über die
ursache
ja die ursache ist nach wie vor unklar
man kann sich das jetzt so auch die
stelle noch nicht erklären warum der zug
war sie auf gerader strecke das war der
langgezogene kurve entgleist ist gab er
keinen gegenverkehr ist eine einspurige
strecke die wir hier sehen was
mittlerweile feststeht ist dass
bundeswehrsoldaten gebirgsjäger aus
mittenwald in diesem zug selbst
betroffen waren und dann sofort vor ort
erste hilfe geleistet haben und ein
bisschen rettungseinsatz koordiniert
haben bis die ersten rettungskräfte
eingetroffen sind ja ich muss jetzt
geklärt werden wir sind jetzt hier
experten auch vor ort sich das angucken
und leitung der staatsanwaltschaft
münchen 2 und wer die kriminalpolizei es
auch vor ort aber das wird vermutlich
noch mehrere tage oder wochen dauern
dass man hier eine endgültige
entscheidung treffen kann was hier genau
passiert ist was dir was die ursache ist
ja seit drei tagen gilt ja dass neun
euro ticket jetzt ist ferienbeginn in
bayern war der zug besonders voll
im zug waren 150 personen der zug
verkehrt nach münchen in richtung norden
der ist eigentlich immer gut besucht
sind wieder drin die dann zum wochenende
in die großstadt fahren wollen 150
personen sind bisher davon sind 15
personen schwer verletzt vier sind ums
leben gekommen eine person wurde eine
person die verstorben ist ist auf dem
weg zum krankenhaus gestorben und das
ganz tragisch ist kurz vor dieser live
schalte jetzt hier im hat mit der
bayerische innenminister joachim
herrmann interview gesagt dass drei
dieser vier toten noch unter den waggons
liegen und noch nicht geborgen werden
konnten ihre identität ist nach wie vor
unklar dafür kann man es hinter mir
vielleicht wirklich mal aus dem bild
bühl steht jetzt ein kran
übergangs anheben soll es wurden auch
ein sichtschutz aufgestellt dass man das
nicht sieht was da jetzt genau passiert
damit man den persönlichkeitsschutz
dieser menschen war man sieht dass die
bergungsarbeiten laufen auf hochtouren
und dann kann man erst sagen wer da
genau drin gesessen hat die sorge ist ja
auch dass schüler unter den opfern
gewesen seien könnten
ja das muss man vielleicht annehmen weil
es gerade 12 und 20 grad am wochenende
letzter tag vor den pfingstferien das
sind gerüchte die hier so kursieren aber
gesicherte erkenntnisse dazu gibt es
auch noch nicht die leichtverletzten
wurden jetzt untergebracht
beim bayerischen roten kreuz werden da
betreut alle anderen wurden in
krankenhäuser gebracht werden auch
teilweise notoperiert also es kann
durchaus sein dass die anzahl der
todesopfer noch nach oben auch die
bundesinnenministerium nancy faeser ist
unterwegs zum unglücksort
viel polizei auch dort weil in der nähe
in erneuerer der g7
stattfinden wird also es wird noch eine
längere bergungseinsatz werden
das auf jeden fall das ist die frage wie
lange dauert das jetzt hier bis dann
diese strecke auch wieder freigegeben
werden kann
das hat in der vergangenheit immer
ziemlich lange gedauert dann muss ich
dann anschauen wie ist die schiene
welchen zustand ist das wie ist das
kiesbett das muss vermutlich auch alles
weggeräumt werden das kommt jetzt genau
gerade zur unzeit denn wirklich am ende
des monats am 26 juni startet der g7
gipfel wenige kilometer entfernt hier
auf schloss elmau und ja die
bundesministerin auch heute beim
abschluss der innenministerkonferenz
in würzburg war mir gleich in kürze
erwartet
mindestens vier toten nach einem
schweren
zugunglück in der nähe von garmisch
partenkirchen kelkheim war das danke